good evening everybody please take your
seats
as some of you know we uh start these
talks off
with a long short a short film that
exemplifies long-term thinking
this long short is one of the shortest
at 60 seconds
and probably covers the longest time
span at
several million years
formation of rocks
prokaryotic cellular photosynthesis
photosynthesis by blue-green algae
eukaryotic cell organisms
last banded ion formation rise of
multicellular organisms
cambrian's first nation of waxy-coated
algae began
and for the next four and a half billion
years
uh good evening stuart brand from the
long now foundation
as for tonight speaker how many here
have read some
for details of the afterlives
how many have given copies to their
friends
that happens a lot and it's going to
happen more
david eagleman
okay so this is you and
you live in a fantastic terrific
society and you would probably
think that there's no way that
anything's ever going to happen in the
society you can't even imagine
how something like this would would fold
and collapse right it's very difficult
to imagine
but note that you would feel exactly the
same way
if this were you and you lived in the
roman empire you would have thought
exactly that same thing and if you lived
in ancient greece
it's impossible to imagine that your
whole society would fold and collapse
similarly if you were living in ancient
egypt or in the
mali empire in africa it would be very
difficult to imagine these things
but in fact an astounding number of
civilizations have come before us
and they have collapsed and centuries of
progress and development and invention
have caved in on themselves
and what this is left is nothing but
archaeological runes
and scattered genetics so some of these
civilizations here
have declined slowly and others have
suddenly toppled
and scholars are still trying to figure
out why and there's an entire academic
discipline that's devoted towards
figuring out
why societies collapse now
one of the main reasons to figure out
why societies collapse
is to figure out how to avoid that
happening
to us so when you sift
through the evidence about the different
societies
and how they fell you find that there
are things in common
things in common that cause them to
collapse and these include things like
disease and natural disaster and
political corruption
and economic meltdown and resource
depletion
and so the civilizations that survive
are those that have either been
lucky or the ones that have developed
new technologies to circumvent
these challenges so what i'm going to
argue tonight
is that we are a very lucky civilization
because we have sort of
accidentally invented a technology that
i think
obviates many of the threats that have
caused
previous civilizations to collapse this
is a connectivity map
of the internet and what i'm going to do
tonight is present a case that this
rapid electronic network system provides
six very important steps that we would
want
to avoid collapse so i think we're at a
watershed moment
in in our history um and this this
may just be the thing that that saves
our future
so for each step i'm going to explain
why it matters historically
and what still remains for us to do to
keep ourselves
safe so step number one for avoiding the
collapse of civilization
is try not to cough on one another
okay so so this is a virus and
disease epidemics caused by microbes
like this viruses and also bacteria
these are the things that precipitated
the fall of the roman empire
and of the golden age of athens and of
most of the empires of the native
americans
and it's sort of surprising that when
you look at the largest
threat to the survival of civilizations
it's something so small
and in fact it's so invisibly small that
viruses and bacteria weren't understood
until very
recently in history and yet despite
their their small size these have caused
more death and destruction than all the
famines and wars
put together so
take take as an example uh smallpox
which is
which was the most destructive disease
in history it's killed
hundreds of millions of people between
ancient times and
1977 when it was finally eradicated
the romans lost up to a third of their
population in parts of their empire
and about a millennium later what
happened is the crusaders came back from
pillaging distant lands
and they brought an epidemic of smallpox
to europe europeans then went over to
the new world they brought
smallpox to the new world and and in
doing so devastated the
incas and the mayans and other natives
there
and some of you may know in 1707
smallpox wiped out a third of iceland
um so similarly the the black plague
you're sending a pestis
this wiped out a third of europe
starting in 1347 and then it kept coming
back to haunt europe
century after century um yellow fever
so badly decimated napoleon's armies in
haiti
that napoleon gave up the idea of having
a western french empire just because of
yellow fever
because of his 22 000 crack soldiers
that he'd sent to haiti 21 000 of them
died
and and so he gave up and that's why
napoleon sold
the louisiana territory to the united
states because he finally
he said i just don't want to be running
this show
can confronting diseases that i no
longer understand so he um he sold it
for roughly five cents an
acre which in a bloodless manner doubled
the size of the united states
okay and so it goes on and on there are
there are these viruses and bacteria
that have really navigated the course of
history in major ways
and what i'm going to suggest is that
the internet is really our key to
survival here
um and this is for three reasons
first what the internet gives us is the
ability
to work remotely and when you can work
from home telepresently
what this allows you to do is is inhibit
viral transmission by reducing
face-to-face contact the human to human
contact
so in in the face
so here's the idea the next time that
there's a really killer virus coming our
way if businesses are
prepared in advance what they can do is
really leverage telepresence to keep
supply chains
running with the maximum number of
employees working from home
now this isn't going to keep everybody
off the street but it's going to vastly
reduce the density and it turns out
that when it comes to epidemics that's
all you need to do you just need to get
things below
a tipping point so the reason
viruses have this sort of tipping point
is because
viruses have a limited lifetime and a
certain probability of infecting
somebody
and so if you have very low host density
then the virus dies before it can get to
a new host
but as soon as you get enough people
together then it can find new hosts and
you go from some sort of equilibrium
state
into an epidemic it really blows up and
in fact you can see this sort of thing
happening every christmas holiday season
with people shopping in the malls
because they all bunch together
and then you cross over this population
tipping point and then everyone gets flu
and cold okay so now here's the problem
in the past
societies have reacted to epidemics by
bunching together
so for example in medieval europe when
the black plague hit and other plagues
like it
um warring religious factions who spent
all their time killing each other
would would show solidarity in the face
of all this death
by marching together in the streets
together to show that the catholics and
the protestants could be friends
in the face of the plague well that was
a real misstep
in terms of density um
and it turns out that the native
americans in a show of goodwill they
would gather in the tents
of people who were infected with
smallpox everyone would gather together
and again unfortunately that was a
gesture that
was sort of ill-fated and so this is
exactly the fear that all major medical
centers
have the next time we have a major
a new strain hitting us whether it's
avian flu or swine flu or something
the big fear that medical centers have
is that everybody with a cough
is going to come flocking into the med
center to get checked out
and this is really dangerous and so i
think this is the second
great opportunity afforded to us by the
net besides telepresence is is
telemedicine
whereby with increasingly sophisticated
technologies we don't have to have base
patients coming in and bunching up
together
but instead we can have diagnosis from a
distance
okay so the telepresence and the
telemedicine are very useful because
they keep the population density below
a tipping point i think there's a third
benefit that we get from the internet
which is we can optimally direct
resources
when there is an outbreak so uh you may
know that the center for disease control
tracks the flu by tracking what happens
at the local hospitals
now the thing is it takes two weeks for
the cdc to put together their report it
lags the actual
flu outbreak by two weeks so google came
up with a better idea
and what they do is they track where
people are searching for terms related
to the flu
so if they're searching for information
on symptoms or medicines or something
it turns out that over the course of the
nation that serves as an excellent proxy
for where there's a flu
outbreak so while the cdc's report lags
by two weeks google's lags by only a day
so this gives us a very rapid way to
know dynamically exactly where the flu
is and where the outbreaks are are
happening
okay so um unlike previous generations
that were brought down by disease
especially because they didn't know how
to react in terms of density and
sparseness
we can now do better because of the
internet if we're well prepared
when the next epidemic arrives we can
fluidly shift
into a self-quarantined telepresent
society
in which the microbes fail by dint of
host
sparseness and so there's a lot of talk
of course about the ills of social
isolation and everybody's sitting on
facebook but whatever those ills are
it bodes a lot worse for the microbes
than it does for us
so although we're well into the step
there's
there's work to be done if we want to
save our civilization
businesses really need to work on
developing
their disaster plans um and and their
work from home epidemic plans
uh i wrote a paper on this in the
journal nature about five years ago and
i've been watching as businesses have
been doing this i've been monitoring
sort of how this is going
some businesses are doing it most aren't
still it's really important to try to
get businesses to do this and it's
extremely easy to test
right to work out the kinks by having
everybody work from home and then the
second thing as a society
we really need to keep developing
telemedicine and similar ideas like that
so that's step one where the internet
already gets us a long way down that
road
of not coughing on each other
the second way that i propose the
internet is going to
uh avert the collapse of civilization is
is with this you don't want to lose
things so
in um in a battle between
julius caesar and ptolemy viii
julius caesar got backed into a sort of
funny uh military move and what he ended
up doing was burning his own
ships at the dock now military
historians talk about whether it was a
good idea or not but the thing was
he accidentally lit the docks on fire
and that burned down
the library at alexandria now the reason
that was such a tragedy
is because the library at alexandria had
for a very long time
been collecting the manuscripts of every
single person who passed through
the port so if you were going through
alexandria you had to give up your
manuscripts
for careful copying by the scribes
and then they would give it back to you
so what the library housed was
all of the knowledge at that time this
was the repository
the problem was it was the single
repository
and when it got torched um it's it's now
just a memory and the thing is that all
the knowledge collected over that period
of time
was lost entirely in a single fire
and it turns out that the learning and
discovery of the mayans
met the same fate in the bonfires of
the spaniards so of the thousands
of books that the mayans had written
that cataloged all of their learning and
discovery and so on
we only have four of them only four
survive into modern times
now can you imagine somebody trying to
understand our civilization by reading
let's say the bible and frankenstein and
harry potter and twilight
that's the situation we're in where
we're trying to understand the mayans
all of their knowledge is gone it was
burned
um the minoan civilization was a
flourishing civilization
between 2700 bce and 1450 bce
it was on the island of crete they had
all kinds of trade and discovery
here's one of the their frescoes um this
is
known as the face uh the face dose disc
from the minoans
and does anybody know what those symbols
mean nobody does
join the club yeah exactly because it
was completely lost
and in fact in fact they weren't even
called the minoans that's not what they
called themselves that's a name that a
british archaeologist gave to them
because we don't know what they call
themselves so everything they had anew
was lost to us okay so knowledge is hard
won by societies and civilizations but
it's very easily lost
and it proves impossible to estimate the
number of museums and archives and
libraries and houses of learning
that fell under the swords of invaders
or
under the wrecking ball of natural
disasters so the problem is
history is characterized by this sort of
amnesia where you have civilizations
that that flourish if you can imagine
little fires on the surface of the globe
there where there's a fire that happens
for a while
and then it gets doused out for whatever
reason and
everything they learned is now forgotten
so so um the thing is that this
impacts survival this isn't just some
sort of historical interest thing
uh so take as an example inoculation
many people know
that in europe inoculation was
introduced by lady montague
and the idea is that you introduce a
little bit of the virus to somebody and
that confers immunity
to a bigger dose of the virus for
example with smallpox this is where it
was used
well inoculation isn't just a good idea
it's a great idea because it really
reduces the the death rate
but what's not so widely known outside
of western circles is that
uh lady montague didn't didn't invent
this in fact the the ottoman empire
where she first saw it they didn't even
invent it turns out that this
inoculation had been in practice
in china and india and africa for
centuries unbeknownst to the europeans
so for example in china
inoculation was underway since the 10th
century and by the time of the ming
dynasty in the 1500s it was widely
practiced
everybody was doing it but the europeans
had to sort of re-stumble on this on
their own
much later does this matter well you bet
it matters because
millions of people died in the meantime
while this was going on
while some people had the knowledge of
inoculation and others didn't
now edward jenner in 1796
improved on inoculation instead of
injecting somebody with smallpox
you use cow pox instead which makes them
less
sick but it also confers the immunity
well that was a great idea that jenner
had
except we now know that six people
in germany and england had the same idea
and they had shown the success of that
idea but nobody knew what happened is
the little fires got lit but they didn't
spread
so everybody had to independently
rediscover this
now as i mentioned it really matters if
you're if if
these things have to get rediscovered or
if they can catch on and spread
because at the same time that all this
was going on with lady montague and then
later with dr jenner
native americans were dying of smallpox
the knowledge existed in other places in
the planet but they didn't exist
as these whole empires were falling here
okay so what happens is if you can
imagine these little these little fires
going on
i should mention two more examples
actually this is stunning but
did you guys know that basic plumbing
ceased to exist for a millennium
after the collapse of the roman empire
people forgot how to do plumbing they
had to rediscover that
a thousand years later and uh as one
more example
in the year 1900 three different
botanists
independently discovered the rules of
genetic
inheritance which gregor mendel had
quietly published 40 years
earlier it was independently
rediscovered three times in the same
year
so so if you if you can imagine these
little fires you've got inoculation that
goes and then goes away
and you've got basic plumbing and you've
got the rules of genetic inheritance and
what you really want
is for an idea to get discovered once
and then to really catch fire
that's what you want to happen and
that's what the internet is good for
because it's distributed and when you
distribute ideas it can latch on
everywhere and get spread around and in
fact this was one of the original
motivations for the internet was to have
distributed storage and the big idea
is uh when you distribute things bits of
knowledge and transform ideas can latch
on immediately the news spreads
everywhere quickly and redundantly and
it makes it very difficult to
erase so fires like the library of
alexandria
and and floods and so on have a very
difficult time erasing
such a knowledge set so for example in
my field as a neuroscientist
i every day use pubmed which is the
central collection
of all of the biomedical research so
anything that's discovered anywhere on
the earth is going to end up in here
very quickly
and i can find it with a few clicks
right
there's a company called jstor which
some of you may use they they
scan these old archives of all these old
journals from the 16 and 1700s journals
that nobody
goes down to the library and actually
dusts off anymore
now it's fully text searchable you can
find things that were once lost to
history they've been exhumed now
and they're all right there at your
fingertips and of course with something
like google books
you have the world's writing is all
there and it's it's clickable
and discoverable and readable and so the
idea is that
if the mayans had had pubmed they could
have just looked up inoculation
right and and and unlike the library of
alexandria
you can't torch google books like that's
really here to stay
so that's the that's the idea now as an
as
as as an example of the modern
appreciation
of storing knowledge in a redundant
indestructible manner
um everyone recognizes michelangelo's
david
well this is not actually michelangelo's
david this is michelangelo's david
and it's being scanned with a 3d laser
scanner
uh from a group that uh it's grouped
from stanford and university of
washington
and what they did is they scanned the
entire statue what you're seeing on the
right
is a reproduction of it made of a
billion polygons
at a quarter of a millimeter resolution
this is the largest scanned object in
the world right now
and the idea is that if the museum
were to be suddenly destroyed in an
earthquake this statue would not be lost
it's totally reproducible now this is
what's known as the digital michelangelo
project
and you can download this on a cd on
your jump drive it's stored all over the
world
and what this means is unlike by the way
this just got completed a few months ago
so previous to that if uh if this hadn't
been done and there were an earthquake
it would just be utterly lost there
would be no more
statue there now this is just a piece of
art of course but i'm using this as an
example
of the way that we can create things now
and make them
immune against destruction where this
becomes really important is with the
intellectual discoveries that might be
happening anywhere on the earth
and that might become really important
for our future we won't be losing those
ideas anymore
and we can draw on them when we need
them and we're not wasting time with
parallel rediscovery as has happened so
many times
in history so this allows us to
optimally solve
problems including problems that we
don't even know are problems yet
okay so step two is distribute don't
reinvent
now the fast spread of these ideas
obviously injects noise into the
database
but it also very importantly prevents
the loss of discovery
and so in this way societies can sort of
optimally ratchet up
and and we can use the latest bricks of
knowledge in our fortification against
against existential threats um so i
think we're doing a good job here
there's a lot more that we're gonna
develop here for example i don't see
aside from doing digital statutes i
don't see why we couldn't do full
digital cities
and and combine for example flickr and
microsoft photosynth passively
and reconstruct in very fine
three-dimensional detail
everything that's out there and have
that for the future right now that's a
lot of data but in
four years it won't be um
and i've been thinking about ways to
improve information science so that
you could not only make sure that none
of the information is lost but you can
develop
algorithms someday that can actually go
and read all the papers in pubmed
and analyze them and start constructing
new hypotheses
and experiments and that ratchets things
up even faster
so there's a lot of there's a lot of
room to grow here but i think we're well
on our way
for on this step of saving civilization
okay step number three tell each other
about things faster
so what you're seeing in the top left
here is is an image from pompeii
which was uh destroyed when mount
vesuvius blew
and covered the city in in ash uh what
you're seeing in the lower right is the
fresco from from the minoan civilization
that i mentioned before
which was destroyed by a tsunami um
and here we see here the the herapin
civilization
which uh is in between india and
pakistan on the coast
which disappeared entirely and uh and
megiddo which is in modern-day israel
both of these seem to have fallen to
earthquakes
so in all these cases natural disaster
suddenly made a civilization disappear
okay and so when i really started
thinking about the relationship
between natural disaster and the
internet is when i was watching what was
happening
with the california wildfires starting
several years ago
well what happened was californians were
glued
to their television sets trying to
figure out if their
neighborhoods were in danger so here's a
picture from san diego and you can see
the fire
way in the distance what people want to
know is am i in trouble so they turn on
the news stations let's say cnn
and they got disappointed because what
happened was cnn was spending all their
time
covering celebrity mansions and they
were looking at whether
these mansions in hollywood and malibu
were going to be
in danger and somehow you know these
houses were taking up
air time in proportion to their square
footage and if you want to know if your
neighborhood's in danger
that's not useful to you so what
happened you could see this several
years ago happening
something tipped something changed and
what happened is everybody turned off
the tv and they went to their computer
they went they started taking geo-tagged
cell phone pics
they started twittering they started
updating their facebook pages
and what happened is the news started
spreading very
fast the news started spreading in a
very accurate way
faster than the front of the fire and
faster than cnn could cover it because
essentially
we had all these home journalists right
you had journalists embedded
on every block in every home and people
taking information and putting this out
there
and so what happened was this this
decentralization
and this massive networking really sped
up the information in a way that old
news networking
just couldn't compete with anymore
and so that got me thinking about what
happens when you do
and you don't have this kind of
networking in the face of a natural
disaster
so take what happened in december of
2004
when there was uh an earthquake
underneath the ocean
and that caused a massive tsunami that
hit
all the the lip of the indian ocean
there and caused the devastating tsunami
in southeast asia
and it all happened without warning okay
nobody saw this coming people saw the
water receding they thought it was
interesting they went out there
um and and and everybody knows about the
thousands of people that died
contrast this with what happened in the
pacific ocean
um uh just a few days i guess it was
four weeks ago
february 27th what happened was
the pacific ocean has a tsunami warning
system
because in 1964 there was a giant
earthquake in alaska
which triggered a tsunami and after that
happened
scientists went and built the specific
tsunami warning system
and essentially it's a bunch of buoys
that are sprinkled out over the entire
ocean
and they track what's happening in real
time and they're connected to an
informational
way of getting the word out so what
happened on february 27 just four weeks
ago
uh was that there was an underwater
earthquake
and the system picked up the shock waves
and sent out the word
and what happened is within hours the
beaches in hawaii
were completely evacuated there was
nobody there everyone went up to the
high grounds people were sort of
festive about it got a picnic or
whatever but they were up in the high
grounds nobody was on
the beaches the u.s navy took their
ships from pearl harbor and steamed them
out
so they wouldn't be caught in near shore
damage it turns out what happened is
the big wave never came it was sort of a
false alarm but it was a tremendously
successful
test of the system because had the wave
come
nobody would have been hurt because
there was great warning that happened
there
and so the indian ocean
lacks a system like that and so i think
what we have is this fantastic contrast
just in the last few years
of what happens when you do and you
don't have the sort of networked
communication where you can get
the word out very quickly and if you can
imagine
that the minoan civilization had had a
tsunami warning system
then they'd still be here with us and
they'd be sitting in the audience next
to you
okay uh i want to give another example
of how
how having fast information like this
uh impacts existential threats so
imagine that the pompeians had had
electronic communication with mount
vesuvius blue
um and this was in the year 79 and
it actually the the volcanic eruption
actually happened in two phases
so it happened the first day is over the
course of about 20 hours
there was this huge plume of of uh
of pumice that rained about over the
course of a day nine
feet on on pompeii
but that's not what killed people
actually what kills people
often with these volcanic eruptions is
what happened the next day it's called
pyroclastic flow
what pyroclastic flow is is you've got
this hot rock and gas
and dust that's screaming down the side
of the volcano
at a hundred miles per hour and this is
a thousand degrees in temperature
right so this is what kills you and it
turns out
that this is what eventually hit pompeii
and hit all the people that were the
the people that were still there and
this is what killed him it's what
destroyed the city
so by my calculation here's here's uh
vesuvius right here and here's pompeii
by my calculation it would have been
very easy with a networking system for
the pompeians
to march 10 kilometers to the southeast
in about two hours
and they would have all been saved had
they just known that this was coming
right
so the idea is they were stymied by a
lack of information and they were
completely killed and then they were
forgotten
for centuries something that strikes me
as very interesting is that pompeii was
re-discovered in the 1700s
can you imagine now with our network
system forgetting a city
but it was forgotten where it was who
they were it was forgotten until the
1700s
okay so what i've been telling you about
is early warning systems with tsunamis
with volcanoes but but you might be
thinking okay well what about something
really fast like an earthquake
can you you know is that going to help
anybody well maybe not
um but certainly where the net has been
proving very useful lately is with
with aggregating information for the
public for
crisis response so
so just like the information was spread
about the california wildfires quickly
this has all been sort of formalized
this is a site called ushahidi.com and
this was originally built in 2008 to
monitor
violence that was happening in the
elections in kenya but what you're
seeing here
is a real-time map of of areas
of trouble in haiti and so
what what this is is people can
contribute with text messaging
or email or web submission exactly where
trouble is
different sorts of troubles too
emergencies menaces
public health problems all this stuff
and in the in the immediate aftermath
of the haitian earthquake this was a
real go-to site
because everybody on the ground with a
mobile phone
can text and say hey here at this
location
something is happening and and then
everybody gets to see this it aggregates
it
and this optimizes disaster response
okay so there's and i also want to
mention a very interesting twist on this
the fact that people
we know will inevitably nowadays twitter
and text and update statuses from
wherever there's a disaster
actually gives us another way to read
information if things go really badly
so we should be able to assess
spots of really big damage because of
the absence of information
so what i mean is um imagine there's a
really big hail storm somewhere
well there's going to be a lot of
twittering about that but now imagine
that a
giant meteor slams into the united
states somewhere
it's the absence of any twittering
from that spot that's going to carry the
bad news
at the speed of electricity right that's
how we're going to know something really
bad happened there
okay so so the idea is
with step number three here with
advanced communication networks humans
grow closer to omniscience and
omnipresence
and they can spread news of a disaster
faster than the disasters
wave front and in the right
circumstances that head start
can provide the extra hours that saves
us
we still have a long way to go with
monitoring these sorts of disasters
scientists right now are are um
working on putting the same sort of
monitoring system that's in the pacific
ocean
into the indian ocean so that we won't
have a recapitulation of what happened
in 2004
and it's a very good step and we'll
continue to have better and more
accurate
disaster recovery sites and one of the
things that has to be absolutely certain
is that these sites don't go down right
when we need them most
okay step number four how to avert the
collapse of civilization
is you have to minimize tyranny so
political censorship has been a familiar
specter in the last century
with state-approved news outlets in
romania
china cuba iraq and lots of other
countries
the official newspapers of the soviet
union what you're seeing here you've
seen pravda
had a complete lock on the news and you
could and foreign newspapers were only
allowed in
if they were published by communist
parties in other countries and approved
by the soviets
and it wasn't just the newspapers the
soviets had a firm lock on all the
copying machines
so that you couldn't even you know have
self-published books and disseminate
flyers and that sort of thing
and of course the soviets were very fond
of editing photographs
to remove people who had fallen out of
favor
with the party so you see these sorts of
things where people are just gone this
is photoshop before photoshop was cool
right so they were um so they were fond
of doing this sort of thing
this is an unusual effect but even the
weather reports were doctored so
in chanchesku's romania for example it
turns out that certain weather extremes
translate
to time off of work and uh
and so those temperatures were never
reached ever
and and it turns out that stalin did the
same thing because
uh if the weather report suggested that
the sun was not going to shine
on the day of celebration of the labor
movement
then it was doctored so
in all of these cases what the
censorship did is it hobbled cultural
progress and it directly fomented
revolutionary
reactions and the reason is that
censorship never really seems to work
that well with the population
because people never really fall for
doctored messages that easily
the parties always think that they're
going to get away with it but in fact
the the population is is usually smarter
so it doesn't do a regime much good
but but the point i want to make is that
censorship can be even much more
dangerous
than just books and photos and weather
tyranny can actually bring down a nation
so on the far left here is trophee
lyschenko
he was a soviet agronomist who became
extremely powerful in the ussr because
he was favored
by stalin so lyschenko had these
theories about how to grow
wheat and it turns out that we now know
those theories were scientifically
fraudulent
but it didn't matter because he was
favored by stalin he got more and more
power and by the late 1940s
he was completely in control of soviet
agriculture about the way that everybody
had to grow
their wheat okay well the problem is
with the centralized command
is that the soviet union covered 13 time
zones
and had an incredible variety of soils
and climates
and a lot of local common sense by local
farmers and as a result
this central rule setting that happened
it was called lychenkoism
the central rule setting for how to grow
agriculture was
absolutely disastrous for the wheat
crops in the soviet union
the local farmers knew better how to
care for their crops but they were
disallowed this freedom
and what happened is that scientists who
disagreed with lyschenko and in terms of
they were correct
they were disbarred from their position
and several them at least four of them
were
executed based on the fact that they
were disagreeing with his
with his uh genetic theories okay well
historians trace part of the downfall
of the ussr to this catastrophe that
happened with their agriculture
it hobbled the economy and it crippled
the proletariat belief
in in the new system and so the lesson
for history is that having
a centralized tyranny rarely works as
well as having local information and
nested feedback loops
well the internet allows us in a very
natural way it democratizes the flow of
information by giving open access
to everybody to the newspapers the world
to the photographs the world to the
blogs
now obviously some postings that you
find on the internet are full of
doctoring and dishonesty and others
strive for for independence and and
impartiality but in the end everything
is available on the net for the end user
to sift through
and to give reasoned consideration to
and as a result of this
related to this the internet can can
allow for massive
speedy democratic responses to things
so i'm just going to use this as an
example because this happened just four
months ago
on december 30th the canadian prime
minister stephen harper
announced that um he was going to shut
down parliament until march 30th
presumably so he could continue to work
on a stimulus package
but a lot of people knew that the reason
he was doing it is because
he was about to get a vote of no
confidence that would force an election
and maybe force him out of office so
what he does he just shut down
parliament
and he did it on december 30th so that
everybody would be busy with the holiday
season and in fact a lot of people were
busy and sort of didn't notice
well one student noticed and he started
a facebook group
which very quickly got 214 000 members
and through this they were able to
organize rallies all across
canada many of these rallies had 3 000
people at them
and he was able to do this with such
rapidity and effectiveness
in a way that would not have been
possible before the advent of the
internet and of course we see this
all the time now we're seeing this all
over the world
and so um so the idea is that
governments
can be kept in check this way with a
sort of speed that wasn't possible
before
and here's another way that governments
can be kept in check by publicly
aggregating and displaying information
about vote tampering so this is a
growing trend
in many countries this has been used in
the voting the national elections in the
last few years by nigeria in kenya and
afghanistan
among several others and so the idea is
that citizens
using their cell phones can report
disturbances or defamations or vote
tampering
or they can even just report incidents
where things went well
and what this has the effect of doing is
keeping the election fair
and free as possible in fact uh i
mentioned earlier the crisis mapping
tool ushahidi
it was developed in kenya for the 2008
elections
when a lot of violence was going on what
this does is it publicly
shines a light on the elections and and
this is just one way
to keep governments a little bit more
transparent than they might otherwise
volunteer to be on their own
now obviously the benefit
of the internet in shining lights on
governments and minimizing tyranny
is in danger in many places around the
globe uh
as most of you know i'm sure in 2006
google agreed
that they would censor traffic in china
because it was obviously very appealing
to tap into a market of 400 million
people and so as many of you know if you
search for tiananmen square protest
most places in the world on google this
is what you get if you're inside china
and search on tiananmen square
protest then this is what you get
so what happened very recently of course
is that google changed their mind on
this topic
and recently started putting into plan
into
practice ways of circumventing the great
firewall of china
and in doing so they're taking a real
risk about giving up
this giant chunk of market but i think
it's a very admirable thing to do if you
care
about mitigating tyranny and it puts the
chinese authorities in a very difficult
position which is interesting
because there the government there is is
wary of agitating local google users who
tend to be highly educated
and vocal so i bring this up to to
emphasize this point that
minimizing tyranny with the internet is
not is not automatic it's not
straightforward
it's going to require constant vigilance
and in fact
here's another example of that so this
is a map of the internet and
information flow around the world and
how free it is and you can see that the
red areas are sort of the usual
suspects where there's really serious
danger in terms of the openness the
information flow but what some of you
might not know is that the government of
australia
in 2008 decided to try to pass mandatory
isp filtering on all the websites and in
2009
it was leaked that they had a list of
the blacklist
of all the sites that they were going to
filter out now this hasn't actually been
put into practice in australia
but it is a subject of real political
discussion and the government that's in
power
uh wants to do it and this is
this is something for us to really be
aware of because again
while while the internet can reduce the
control of a government
there's constant vigilance that's
required
okay so i mentioned these difficulties
even in the face of these difficulties
it remains likely that future attempts
at censorship are eventually going to be
defeated by the new technology of the
internet or at least the internet will
help with this
and among other things as citizens our
next steps are um
first of all to demand transparency in
government at every point that we can
and this is already underway with sites
like recovery.gov
and um and we should financially
encourage
companies that who stand up against
censorship there there are several
companies now
that are considering pulling out of
china now it's complicated right some of
them have various reasons some of their
servers have been hacked and they're mad
about that
they have various reasons for wanting to
do that but i think it's really
the onus is on us as a population to
give positive feedback to those
companies google stock has fallen six
percent
since they started having this trouble
with china and and that's a shame
um and i think thinking for a little
further into the future
eventually people are going to get very
good at having home brewed satellite
uplink systems which means that you can
circumvent government firewalls
altogether
and so i think all these steps are going
to be very important in terms of
minimizing tyranny
and the internet is one of the
technologies that can really help us get
there
okay step five if you want to save
civilization is you get more brains
involved
in solving problems um okay so we all
know about crowdsourcing
and the idea here is that you solve
problems by massive participation
and what you do is you get lots of
people together and they're essentially
the nodes
of the super computer and there's been a
lot of it's been a lot of scholarly
writing and popular writing about
the wisdom of crowds and the fantastic
uh properties you get out of
crowdsourcing
so for example on the site foldit
protein
folding is an extremely intensive
computational problem
and the idea here is that you turn it
into a game and you have end users
work on the game see how they can fold
it and see you can get the minimum
energy configuration
and then you can win prizes and so on so
what you're doing is you're distributing
this very hard problem to lots and lots
of people it's a great idea for
crowdsourcing
sea start is a new uh organization
that's just begun
and their idea is to do open source
knowledge gathering to get to the moon
so we don't have to depend on
governments anymore we're going to get
to the moon ourselves by everybody
sort of pitching in in the same way that
you can do open source movements to
develop really good software
so that's the idea with with
crowdsourcing
but what i want to point out is that
crowdsourcing
really the way it's going now it
involves less than one percent
of the world population who are actually
involved in this sort of thing and i
want to suggest an important way to go
beyond crowdsourcing so 80 years ago
virginia woolf in her essay a room of
one's own she pointed out
that half the planet's writing talent
had been squandered by the simple fact
that women at that time didn't have the
same opportunity as men to become
writers and she imagines in this book
what would happen
if william shakespeare had a sister
named judith shakespeare who was equally
as talented
what would have happened and her answer
is we would have never heard of judah
shakespeare
because she simply wouldn't have had the
opportunity and that's a real waste
of human capital so human capital is a
term that was originally defined by adam
smith
and it refers to the skills of the labor
force and it turns out that it's now
becoming clear that the development of
human
capital depends on open access
to education and opportunities and many
economists
have been have been really emphasizing
lately the importance of human of
cultivating human capital
because the investment translates
directly into economic
output and and in a world where we know
that historical collapse is so tightly
tied to economic meltdown
civilizations would be well advised to
leverage all the brain
power that they have the problem is
most of the world doesn't have the
opportunity to get the education that's
afforded to a small minority
and so for every einstein or yo-yo ma or
barack obama
who has the opportunity for education
there are uncountable others who just
never get the chance
and this vast undertapping of our
civilization's potential
steals security from our future so
the internet addresses this problem with
a kind of natural ease
by opening the gates of education in a
way that's never been possible before
so a motivated teen anywhere on the
planet
can start walking through the world's
webs of knowledge starting with
wikipedia
and then going to mit's open courseware
and getting an ivy league education
many universities launch this sort of
thing rice university has a
site called connections which is
essentially wikified textbooks
from children to professionals and it's
been very successful
so for the intrepid learner anywhere on
the globe
if she can get a hold of the internet
there are tens of thousands of courses
online
there are lectures there are lecture
notes there are homework problems
there's quizzes
interactive web demos and so on
and beyond and beyond the courses the
world's
scientific knowledge is now at the
fingertips of everyone
so hunting down a scientific paper when
i had first started graduate school you
have to walk over the library
now everything's at at your fingertips
and the national institute of health
has demanded that all the papers that
are published on their dime in other
words any scientist who has an nih grant
now has to upload the published
manuscript to pubmed central
so the idea is that for the taxpayers
the fruits of their labors
should be right there at their
fingertips if they're the ones
contributing to the research
they should be able to access that and
same with archive.org you've got all the
physics
papers available so all of the world's
knowledge is available right there to
anyone who can get a hold of the
internet
and if you're ever going to be a medical
patient of course now is the right time
to do it
until recently physicians had a lot of
asymmetric knowledge over the patients
but with the proliferation of medical
web portals
and sites where patients get together
and share information the patients are
better educated and that ends up being
better for everyone
okay so i know what you're thinking
you're thinking you know it's not
actually trivial
for kids in impoverished countries to
get a hold of the internet
and much of the world does not have
access still nonetheless even the mere
feasibility of it completely redefines
the playing field
and people are working on getting
computers into the hands of children all
over many of you familiar with the
one laptop per child program which
builds
very cheap computers and allows children
to have these so that they can have this
self-empowered learning there was a lot
of development that went into one laptop
per child to make these computers very
inexpensive
and negra ponti the guy who's been
leading this charge just announced that
they're working on
a new model of the computer which will
be based on the tablet model
and the advantage here is that it's a
lot cheaper and more robust to build
because the former model has 900 moving
parts including the keyboard and the
hinge and so on
whereas a tablet model has none of that
so you can do it for cheaper and it's
more robust
and you can get this into the hands of
even more children so this is a program
that's underway and it's been
tremendously successful
so i talked a few steps ago
about the retention of knowledge and the
speed of spreading knowledge but what
i'm really talking about here is the
creation
of knowledge and i and i'd like to be
able to come up with a better word than
crowdsourcing which as i mentioned
just uses less than one percent of the
population working on these problems
and and since there will be problems in
the future that we haven't even thought
of
in the face of that what we want to do
is maximize our problem-solving
machinery and so
what i think we want to do as we
democratize education is move from
crowdsourcing
really to something like society
sourcing where we're getting
10 50 of the population involved
in really solving problems it goes
without saying that vast numbers of
people on the planet
will not take the opportunity to give
themselves an ivy league education
but for the first time in history it's
widely available
so we've the internet has sort of
naturally accomplished a human resource
capitalization that would make judith
shakespeare proud
we're finally in a position to actualize
the brains
available in our worldwide population
there are a lot of steps that we need to
do next we need to keep increasing sites
and applications for crowdsourcing
contribute to open courseware support
open access publishing
in all areas financially incentivize
that
and improve information science i can go
into that a little bit more
[Music]
finally the last step if you want to
avert the collapse of civilization is
try not to run out of energy
so um
so it turns out that carrying capacity
is one of the
is one of the main concerns on the mind
of scientists and and politicians and
thinkers
it's the fugacity of the the natural
energy resources that we have is really
the concern because
when societies exceed their carrying
capacity in other words how much
energy is available to support them
that's when all is lost that's when they
start fighting for the resources
that are there and everything goes down
the tubes
so this characterizes many different
types of collapses that have come before
us so in jared diamond's book collapse
he points out that a common reason for
societal failure
is environmental damage for example
deforestation or soil erosion
and in in his book ancient maya arthur
demarest points out that
the same thing that drought and a loss
of soil fertility
precipitated the fall of the mayans even
before the smallpox arrived
and and it turns out that just recently
people have come up with um
evidence for the exceedance of carrying
capacity
among the minoans the civilization that
i mentioned before that got wiped out by
a tsunami
it turns out that archaeological
recovery shows evidence for
deforestation around that part of crete
meaning that if a tsunami didn't get
them carrying capacity issues might have
okay well happily the internet again
addresses this sort of problem with a
very natural ease i was recently just
giving a talk at the nih in bethesda
and i was absolutely amazed by these
atavistic filing cabinets
that that lined the hallways and the
rooms and they
filled everything with this unnecessary
gravity
and no one accesses these anymore
because all the important papers of
course have shifted into electrons at
this point
so what these do they remain in the
hallways is this this
fossil-like evidence of a recent age in
which you measured information content
not by gigabytes but by by cubic meters
and and the inefficiency of these giant
filing systems has characterized
everything businesses and science until
very recently
and i'm going to suggest that the
technological shift from bigger to
to smaller is more than convenient it's
absolutely critical to the future
so take for example our mail service
since the introduction of email our
postal system
which has now been demoted to the
moniker of snail mail has been
hemorrhaging financially and they've
been raising their stamp prices
continually
to try to keep up why because
everybody's sending their documents
electronically whether it's real estate
contracts or book manuscripts or
whatever it is
everybody's sending this electronically
and it's very difficult to estimate the
billions of pounds of carbon dioxide
saved by not having to ferry batches
of paper everywhere for simple
transactions but we can be sure
that this makes it the contribution to
air quality
and and similarly we've we've diminished
the need to drive long distances to
browse and purchase
products and this has allowed many brick
and mortar stores
to shift a lot of their operation online
so if you're shopping for a perfect
set of cutlery or dishes or a shirt or
something you might have previously
driven around to several stores to look
for this to look over the stock
and now it's replaced with some minutes
of web surfing you find exactly what you
want at the best price
and you click to get a single delivery
now i know what you're thinking you're
thinking okay well what makes you think
that the delivery trucks
are any better for the environment than
if you drove around well there's a
couple things
um it turns out that one thing you might
worry about is all the packaging that
involves in delivery but of course all
the companies now are moving towards
more eco-friendly packaging
they call it eco-friendly packaging but
they're of course they're saving
themselves money
the only reason that they ever had big
packaging
was to prevent um shoplifting right you
have to put things in big display
packages so people can't stick it in
their pocket and walk out
well now you don't have to do that and
companies increasingly they're all
advertising how they're saving more and
more and more on their packaging so now
things are very tight
okay but obviously we still have to
worry about the trucks driving around
but the good news is everybody's trying
to save money and energy
and so it turns out that companies like
ups
who deliver these things have developed
these super
optimization algorithms where they can
figure out how to make deliveries in the
most optimal way possible
and some of you may know that ups trucks
don't even make left turns anymore
why because left turns are terrible you
sit there you idle you waste a lot of
time and gas and you have to go again
so ups they never make left turns
anymore they're super optimized and as a
result
they've saved millions of miles off
their delivery route they've saved
millions of gallons of gas and they've
reduced co2 by a lot
okay so in many cases it turns out it
actually is
much more efficient to have these things
delivered to you and to your neighbors
rather than you driving all over town
in your inefficient sitting alone in
your car
left turning method okay
um and then finally it's the case uh
uh so i'm a scientist and i see this all
the time people in businesses and other
people see this
in your own ways all the time but we're
having more and more meetings online so
um a few months ago i was invited by the
journal nature to give a
talk in second life and i was able to
use powerpoint slides and people dropped
in
from all around the world to hear the
talk and it was a fantastic experience
for me because
there was not a drop of jet fuel burned
for all the people to come
and hear the talk it was it was seamless
and it was
absolutely environmentally friendly now
there are of course real costs to the
forest of computers
that underpin the internet but these
costs are far less than the trees
and the coal beds and oil deposits that
would be spent down for the same amount
of information flow
and a lot of people are working on ways
to produce electricity more cheaply and
quickly
but there aren't any such plans for
trees and coal and oil
so to summarize this many authors have
pointed out that
societal collapse can typically be cast
in terms of energy
when energy expenditure begins to
outweigh energy return
that's when collapse ensues so the next
time you're annoyed by the accumulation
of emails
in your email box just think about how
grateful you are that it's not all
packages and papers like it was in the
old days
um okay so what to do next well i think
it would be really useful
for companies to commit to server farms
run on sustainable energy
governments can incentivize us with tax
breaks and
you know i don't see in the future why
we can't have mobile phone apps where
you're
where you're minimizing your own routes
and doing no left turns and figuring out
exactly how to go
places and this is just in the near
future i think in the far future we're
going to have even better ways
involving crowdsourcing and other
methods of really getting better
energy efficiency okay
so in jared diamond's book collapse
he points out that societies often fall
because of malfunctions in long-distance
trading for needed resources
and i think through the modern lens we
can suggest that maybe the most
important trade works nowadays the trade
networks nowadays
are carrying zeros and ones they're
informational they're in other words
instead of sort of the silk route
it's it's the fiber optic trading routes
and and what i've argued is that the
internet can
in a very natural easy way defy six
problems that play traditional roles
in societal collapse and these are the
problems now
of course i'm sure some people are
scribbling down questions now saying you
know
it's more complex than that and that's
exactly right there are a lot of things
that the internet will only address
tangentially
there are many scholars who address why
civilizations collapse
uh some point out that um very general
things they
they they don't change their fixed
design for solving problems or
they find problems that they cannot
solve these are two famous ideas about
why societies collapse they're very
general
i actually think that even though it's
sort of tangential here the internet
with the crowdsourcing the
democratization of education and so on
the speed of information i think it
might actually be able to touch on these
there are others that it probably won't
be able to touch on directly
tumen and bennett in 1948 listed many
prerequisites for civilization's
survival i've picked out some here that
i think the net doesn't directly address
basic nutritional needs construction of
a good legal system
maintenance of order with good executive
and judicial branches
and having meaningful diplomacy abroad
these are all things that maybe the net
doesn't directly address and then
i'm sure somebody scribbled this down on
a piece of paper already there's a
really big problem with everything i've
been saying which is
what happens when the net goes down and
we are completely married to this i mean
it's already the case that we're in this
situation but
but i'm arguing that it'll save
civilization and here's the real
achilles heel to the argument here
so i think there are at least two ways
that the net will go down
one of course is major electricity
outages
and um i think what's going to need to
happen is people are going to
need to think very hard about backup
plans not only for the server farms but
the routers the end users people having
ways at their own homes to run this and
it might not just
you might not want to just have it solar
because there might be something like a
nuclear winter
where there is no sun you maybe want
wind i mean there are a lot of really
bad scenarios you can imagine
where the net would go down and you're
completely dependent on it and you want
some way
that the whole society has a backup plan
here and i have a suspicion
that the net's going to go down a few
times before people get really good
about having home backup plans and
everybody
along the way has a good a good method
for this
and then of course there's going to be
network attacks
and we're already seeing some of this
the internet and iran went down recently
and i haven't been able to find out
exactly
the follow-up on what happened but but
at the time they were saying it looked
like cables were cut these undersea
cables
and i think the jury's still out about
exactly what happened if it was
purposeful or not
what's clear is that in warfare of the
future we're not going to be talking
about
just having rugged soldiers in camos and
machine guns we're going to be talking
about
young people in their workout clothes
slamming energy drinks
and fighting national wars this way with
cyber warfare this is really as we get
more and more married and
interconnected with the internet that's
going to be the future of warfare
so i just want to wrap up with making
one statement given
how married we are to the internet and
given that this is the thing that might
save us in various ways i think we
should probably have something like
an equivalent of the seed vault this is
the seed vault in svalbard
which holds 500 000 different types of
plant seeds
and the idea is that if there's some
global catastrophe
you've got a backup of everything here
and you can actually reconstitute
the crops of the world by pulling them
out of this
seed bank and svalbard and so we need to
have some sort of internet seed bank and
i'm not
talking about the internet archive or
just having a copy of what's been
happening on the internet i'm talking
about
things burned into physical media that
teach you how to generate electricity
how to build a computer and how to
reconstitute
the net because we might have backup of
all the data on the net
but someday if things get really
disastrous we're going to be able to
actually know how to rebuild
the net so that's all i'm going to say
and i'm happy to
take questions now thank you so much
let's go see it
a couple questions about um you know the
net savings and you said what if the net
goes down
what is a neuroscientist doing thinking
about all this stuff
i just have to and writing short stories
well
i i oh yeah i think i have two different
answers to that um
neuroscience is such an exciting field
and that's where i spend all of my day
right
but we just happen to be this incredible
time where everything's changing so
rapidly around us as you and everyone
here knows
it's just such a great time it would be
impossible to not think about those
other issues and i've always been a real
student of history i've been a real
history buff
so it's impossible not to think about
what's happened before
and how this is changing it so i found i
couldn't help but do that does it feed
into your science at all to do this
i mean if you become a best-selling
story writer that will help finance your
science but how about intellectually
right
well interestingly the fiction writing
and the science go together very well
because
the way science actually works as many
people here know
what's written in the textbooks is
completely untrue science never goes as
a linear process of discovery
it's always people making creative leaps
it's people you go into lab every day
and you make
up the wackiest stories that you can and
you see which ones
you can build a bridge of evidence back
to what we already know
but often what happens is you end up on
some really interesting island
and you can't do any science with it but
you can go home at night and use
literature as a as a channel for
exploring that more
and so i use literature and science it's
both the same thing it's just it's
creative ideas and getting to explore
those and see what happens with it
and in general art and science is really
the same thing it's it's just trying to
figure out what is the essence of
something
how do you how do you get it down i've
gotten the sense that science has
flipped from my generation to yours in
my generation
biologists for example morphologists
would
master a certain body of science and
then sequester it
and valve it out very carefully and
that's how they got power
and then along came genbank and now it
looks like
uh you know sharing half-baked
information practically in real time
is almost how people move ahead in
science is that
i'm not sure about the half-baked part
but but you do want to get it out there
as quickly as you can
yeah that seems right one cookie at a
time you don't need to do a whole
but as long as it's fully cooked that's
right that's right i mean the paper is
getting smaller
you know the royal society sort of
invented the scientific paper
and are they getting into smaller
fragments or more authors or what's the
what's the trend there i don't think so
because i was just recently reading on
jstor these old archived papers i was
reading
issues of science and nature from like
1910 and they were extremely short
papers that had very little
a guy said dear sirs i was sitting on my
porch listening to the cicadas
and i noticed that there's a certain
rhythm to it and that was a science
paper at that time
so yeah i think i think they've become
more sophisticated i mean in fact the
competition's become very fierce
because there are so many smart kids
going into science now
um you know the field's very they the
the saying i don't know how anyone
measured this but saying is that
80 percent of what we know in
neuroscience we've learned in the last
20 years
um as a result there's just lots of
competition
for for some limited amount of room in
the journal so is that going to keep
happening is the next 20 years going to
be another 80
is that some some kind of exponential
hard to say i mean we've we've
learned so much in neuroscience but
there's actually a problem i know there
are a few neuroscientists here in the
audience who's a neuroscientist here
yeah who's a neuroscientist you got
thank you okay we got a few um you know
the deep problem in neuroscience now
is that we don't really know how the
brain works we don't know what the
theory of the brain is we don't even
know what the theory is going to
look like because when you take the deep
problem of consciousness
which is how you ever put together
physical pieces and parts and get
private subjective experience out of it
none of the kind of ways we have making
theories now will ever answer that
there's no
amount of tinker toys that you can put
together and then suddenly you put one
more and you say ah now it
it's having the taste of feta cheese or
something so
so this is the great unsolved problem in
neuroscience and and the fact is that
our books keep getting thicker and
we have a book in the field called
principles of neural science which is
that
fat and i don't think you can call it
principle because if it were really
principles it would be thin if we knew
more it would be a pamphlet
but what this means is we're just
dumping everything in there because we
don't really understand how it fits
together right now
bernard avengers said to one of these
audiences that um
the singularity might happen when the
net wakes up
does that mean anything it might um
so the
one of the theories on the table now we
don't know if it's right but it's it's
the computational hypothesis of the
brain function which is that
really what's important is not the wet
gushy stuff
but the algorithms that are running on
top of that and and so if this
computational hypothesis is true it
means that you could reproduce
if i reproduced your brain out of beer
cans and tennis balls
and it was running the same software it
would be you and i could have this
conversation with
with that brain um if that's true we
should be able to reproduce things in
zeros and ones on computers someday and
download ourselves into the matrix as
well
but if it's all true it means that the
city of san francisco might be conscious
it means that the net might be conscious
if really what it is is a bunch of
physical pieces and parts interacting
in ways that are running algorithms once
we understand what those algorithms are
um we might find that a lot of stuff is
is conscious and we just don't have you
know san francisco doesn't have ears and
a mouth to
to ask it and have any kind of
meaningful communication an example of a
brain algorithm that we've sorted
already
oh um we don't have any real complete
ones but we
i mean we know a lot about uh how the
visual system works it's probably the
best understood part and then the other
sensory systems and we know more and
more about the front half of the brain
which is about making executive
decisions and so on um
but we we don't yet have anything where
we can simulate in a computer and say
well now it's conscious and there's an
interesting legal thing in the future
here which is once we simulate
consciousness on a computer
then you can't turn it off because
that'd be murder right yeah
yeah and we always project that it'll
object but you know maybe it says turn
me off this is horrible
okay we'll get dr kevorkian to turn it
on yeah
this leads right into a question from
paul barrell
what do you think of joseph tainter's
thesis that complexity causes the
collapse of societies you've just
described
endless complexity here and that it's
all good
is tinder for lunch well there's this
idea um
and i'm afraid i've just forgotten the
name george white sides is that the name
of the guy who said they have stacked
complexity
which i hope i get this right but the
idea is you start something very simple
like the transistor and you build more
and more complex things like the
computer
but eventually what this leads to is
new simplicity like google where it's
just a page and you type a word and you
find something
so so as complexity increases it tends
to sort of re-collapse into simplicity
and so given the points that i um was
making today about the internet and all
these ways where it'll save civilization
i guess i disagree with tainter on that
um i think complexity has led to new
simplicity which is gonna be thing that
saves us
scott ether smith says we're calling
daniel suarez's lecture
in this series on bot mediated reality
do you think there may be new challenges
to this ability of civilization to come
from the internet
and kevin kelly who processed this said
this this is a new way to collapse
society you have to you have seven
things to deal with yeah well what i i
didn't see suarez's talk but it was
bought mediated reality
i mean is this the idea of the net
waking up in a bad way like in the
terminator skynet
uh it's just that they're basically
malware
uh rules ah
here's what i think um so since the long
now foundation is interested in
the ten thousand year scale i thought
what if we considered
ten thousand years what if we mapped a
single human lifetime onto those ten
thousand years
uh if we did that if we mapped a human
lifetime on to that it means that the
internet is now
two and a half months old and what that
means is that any prognostication we
make about the net
is going to stink we just don't know
because we're too early in it
it's just learning how to stick its
tongue out and so um
so my answer would be maybe maybe we're
in real trouble with the net
all the prognostications i'm making are
just the most primitive ones based on
extrapolating what we have right now
sounds to me like sticking his tongue
out makes me think that the
metaphors for the net are going to
always be insufficient for understanding
what's going
on with it i mean in a sense you're sort
of mapping old civilizational problems
onto well we solve that with this and we
solve that with that and all these net
capabilities
the technology makes us lucky in a sense
um but i suppose this is a version of
the singularity problem is it you know
if we can't under if we can't grasp
what's coming
because of all this acceleration you're
talking about
uh does failure to grasp what's coming
become itself a problem
um yes but it's one that we can't do
anything about prognostication has
always been bad
and so my point number five on there
was that really what you want to do when
you can't see what the problems are that
are coming
is you want to really leverage your
human capital you want to get
everybody involved in solving problems
and i think that's probably our only
defense our best defense for problems
that we can't
foresee this quest that point is
greatly anticipated by a question from
brian what difference do you think we
would see when 10 to 50
of the world's population is involved in
crowdsourcing in its various forms
i know yeah these are all great
prognostication questions and i just
don't know the answers to these
well what we're looking at is you know
we talked about you know there's
there's always more bandwidth there's
always more
but engineers say any 10
quantitative change is a qualitative
change this just described the
qualitative change in crowdsourcing
um sort of extrapolating from you now
tracking how many
different kinds of problems
crowdsourcing can step up to
play that forward a little bit yeah
well there might be more open source
projects i hadn't heard of sea star
until just a few days ago i don't know
how long it's been around but the idea
of an open source project to get to the
moon really captured my imagination i
thought what a what a wonderful idea
and if it works i mean who knows if it
will but if in 15 years from now there's
some sort of
you know like linux version of getting
to the moon that's really
that's really superb and maybe what
we'll start seeing is more of that stuff
and um a move away from
yeah from big corporations i mean you
know we've got problems with tyranny and
governments
uh but of course a concern that people
have always had
spengler in his decline of the west was
concerned about
rule by the wealthy is you get these
corporations and they take over and then
you don't have good social mobility of
the poor
maybe this is the thing that will lead
to good social mobility of the poor and
will avoid
spengler's pratfall um of just having
the corporations and the wealthy take
over everything
you may have just framed the next
discussion we're having on global
deviant globalization where basically
the poor the outlaws
that used to be poor i have this whole
other version
of non-corporate ways to build wealth
and even to build governance in a
certain way
and that sounds like from your
standpoint uh work around to some of the
problems of the uh standard
globalization yeah
maybe yeah either that or it helps break
it down
i mean what you know does banditry help
or hinder
uh civilizations yeah it should
i don't know banerjee probably hinders
um yeah i don't know i don't know
anything about banditry really
but i think
work on that all right i'll get back to
you
jay cross asks how can we satisfy people
dedicated to preserve religious memes
started long before the information age
you know the wisdom of the ancients what
do they know they didn't have cell
phones
yeah yeah um i mean this is something
that's been amazing to me for a long
time right the people who wrote these
holy books
didn't know the size of the cosmos they
didn't know bacterial infection
computation quantum they didn't know any
of this stuff
so the philosophers russell and white
had suggested a long time ago look if
you're going to have spirituality
you might as well predicate it on the
bedrock of what we already know to be
true we know so much
about the size of the cosmos now for
example you might as well start there
and in fact carl sagan echoed this he
said
he said i can't believe that religions
haven't taken this on board
and said wow the cosmos is even more
wonderful than we thought it's more full
of awe than we thought there are
sextillion stars out there there's any
number of
extraterrestrial civilizations that's
fantastic but
you know for reasons of retaining seats
of power and so on yeah religions tend
not to take this stuff
on um i have no idea where i was go
where are we going
like a train wreck anyway well it's
uh in a way the question was making a
case for
creative forgetting um because in a
sense you're saying hey
we're moving up the capability to
basically remember everything and access
everything and uh are the problems with
that
oh oh um people get locked into
a grand old idea and sort of swear
romantic allegiance to it and then act
according to it
uh which is easy to do because they've
got you know they collect online lots of
people who feel the same
next thing you know they're they're in
michigan practicing uh
with rifles you're right well now this
um wait i'd like to ask a show of hands
how many people know what the ultra
deep field experiment was done by nasa
the ultra deep field experiment
this is okay so maybe maybe seven what's
that
that they know more than i do that's
free okay right and this is extremely
educated credit right and only seven
percent
so uh this is a quick tangent but to me
this is the most amazing
thing that i know and it has theological
implications it has implications for how
everybody should be thinking about so
um what happened was nasa took the
hubble space telescope which is in
geosynchronous
orbit and they decided they were going
to instead of sort of mapping the skies
they were going to pick one little
spot dark spot and point the telescope
at that and see if maybe they could
detect a star there even though you
could even those black
so they picked a nice spot that didn't
have any earth shine or galaxy dust
and they pointed the telescope at it and
they did this 400 times every time the
hubble came around
and they collected a million seconds
worth of data and when they exposed it
what they wanted to see is even on that
spot it's about the size of a pencil tip
even though that spot looks pitch black
was there anything behind there when
they exposed it what they found
was not a star not a bunch of stars they
found 10
000 galaxies in that spot in space
a galaxy consists of a hundred billion
stars so when you look at that and you
think about the number of planets and
extraterrestrial life forms and so on
and that's one spawn space if you wanted
to map out all the space that resolution
would take a million years right
so it makes you think wow everybody's
story is
really limited and i think that's what
technology does
is it's going to it's going to force an
improvement of people's stories
and and um i think as experiments like
this become well known
it'll be harder and harder for somebody
to cling to a story that's millennia
old they'll just be confronted with so
much new data
that it'll sort of take the wind out of
the sales of their story that's what i
think it has to happen
i used to know carl sagan i feel like
you're he's back
[Music]
kevin kelly had one uh if a small virus
can take down an
ancient civilization then why can't a
computer virus take down the internet
and civilization oh boy it can that's
where the future of cyber warfare is i
mean i think
i think it's going to be really
worrisome um
yeah that's that's the achilles heel and
the whole argument i made
is is what happens is people as it
becomes more and more important for
nations to clip undersea
cables or have viruses in their there
yeah so we have to be very careful as
long as the internet works it's
absolutely going to save us in all kinds
of ways
but but we're really in trouble when
that goes down what if
do you have any theories from sort of
brain study as to
i mean the brain is this tremendously
sensitive networked
thing that has developed various
protective mechanisms and so on
presumably it has some in software
so what would a brain scientist tell the
network engineer to
do to head off this kind of problem
that's a that's a great question it
turns out they're so different because
networks at the beginning
worry about things like feedback and
redundancy and how to make sure things
don't go into epilepsy
whereas everything that evolves through
time
um you know it's just all this craziness
piled on top of each other through
through deep time uh and so brains have
to make all these broken rococo
corrections to things to make sure that
things don't blow up and of course they
do blow up all the time with
epilepsy and brain tumors and strokes
and so on
i hope because of ways that engineers
are building the net from the beginning
that we won't have the equivalent to an
epileptic seizure or stroke
or a brain tumor in the network but if
we're to take the matrix as any guide
when you have a system that big you find
anomalies in the matrix that you just
can't help because the system is too big
so maybe that will happen well this
leads to
um and we're trying to reverse
engineering the brain which is
reverse engineering 20 million
generations of morons
doing the least bad thing
20 million in one yeah
those are all the mothers
and so what you're suggesting is
suggests to me anyway a less baroque
less rococo
dead at it just you know do it uh
approach to brain design which when we
get far enough into the reverse
engineering maybe we're already there
we can start saying well nice try but we
can do better
and we'll we'll make a better brain from
the ground up is that what you see
that's true although the truth is that
that's the approach that started in the
1960s with this idea of artificial
intelligence
the idea was you know the brain's really
messy and complicated and has a lot of
history to it why don't we just start
from scratch and event intelligence
and um when i was a kid growing up i
thought for sure by 2010
we'd have robots everywhere and the best
thing we've got is the roomba vacuum
cleaner
so something went really wrong there and
this was the 1960s we essentially threw
the smartest guys on the planet at this
problem
and it failed artificial intelligence is
a failed field and the lesson that we
learned from that is that actually
mother nature is really clever and it's
a really hard problem
and so the game shifted at some point
maybe starting the 80s and 90s the game
really shifted to
okay fine let's look in the brain and
let's actually copy what's going
on there and try to figure out what the
algorithms are instead of circumventing
it that's been the recent history you
know what happened to all those ai guys
they went into finance
[Laughter]
i'll bet and we're running you know the
world banking system
is that what always happens from the
best and brightest all swarm to some
particular area do you think
that that that will that that well it
will yeah it will crash in a superfluity
of hubris or something
and can we point them at less delicate
parts
[Laughter]
are you going to get to actually stay a
scientist do you think and think of all
this because you're going around giving
you've worked in london you gave how
many talks in england
uh five yeah but one of them was the
keynote speech of the scientific
conference
here's the thing i hope to everybody's
asking me this question um
i hope to remain a scientist because
i've put so much work to get here and
this is really the golden age of
neuroscience this is really when it's
all happening
and um this would be the worst time to
jump ship from that so i'm i'm gonna
make
you know i go into lab every day from
nine to nine and i work really hard at
running that laboratory
and then when i go home at night that's
when i do the other stuff that's when i
write fiction or
write long now talks um but uh yeah i'm
gonna remain a scientist
that's why your afterlife stories are
such good bedtime reading we've found
because if they work for you
keeping you awake putting us to sleep
with weird dreams i mean
[Laughter]
what an amazing thing to do to sort of
program other people's dreams
does this mean you're doing stories
there for one officer are you going to
do
another domain of do you think oh um i'm
doing another domain off so the
the biggest compliment that i got with
some was that it was unique that there's
not another book like it
so my next book is even uniqueer so um
so it takes place over 200 billion years
with a single narrator it takes place
over the course of several cosmoses
some some of you may know that
astrophysicists are debating this issue
about whether there's enough
gravitational pull
that the expanding universe will
eventually slow down and stop and come
back together
and if it does if that's the right model
there's going to be a big crunch
and everything that we've ever developed
all our literature and love letters and
art and so on everything will be utterly
destroyed in the collapse of the
universe
but the good news is there'll be enough
energy there to cause the next big bang
and if this model is right it means that
our entire cosmos
is one in a series an infinite series of
cosmos that have existed before us
and have had their own literatures and
wars and
and arts and so on and they've been
utterly destroyed
so what my next book is doing is taking
um it's asking it's sort of starting
with this question of
if you can imagine a cosmos before us
that was a billion years more advanced
in technology than we are
could they figure out a way to transmit
a message to us
across the cusp of that universal
collapse and if so
what would they send what would we send
right would we send our funniest joke or
you know instructions on head right what
would they send and and whatever message
they send they'd have to assume that
it'll take 14 and a half billion years
until some species
will evolve in the next cosmos to be
able to read it and what should we be
looking for and so that's the fictional
starting point for that book and it
shares the same spirit of
some in that it's short stories that
really point a spotlight
on us and the joys and complexities of
being human but but that's the the
structure of the next one do you have to
sort of portage
through brain theory into another brain
universe
cosmos theory into another universe to
get that message through or
do you see a straight line uh just as
well just a straight line of sending the
message right across but but the message
is something that has to unpack itself
over
oh that's billions of years so you're a
science fiction writer now
well the interesting thing is when i
when i first turned in some to my agent
she said
look no one's gonna know how to market
this they're gonna science fiction and
religion
atheism like no one's gonna know where
tomorrow i said come on just you know
loosen up we get we'll just do
it's literary fiction yeah and um
yeah and so it's really worked that way
as literary fiction and i actually
resist the label science fiction
i don't think it's exactly that let me
give you a reason not to i was uh spent
some time with gregory benford last week
at a
meeting on geo engineering in acelamar
and
he's doing a lot of interesting research
including on geo engineering i said how
do you pay for it he said
i have millions of dollars from selling
science fiction stories
is that at all attractive rather than
you know going begging to in
national science foundation or somebody
well yeah boy
the whole grant making system is totally
broke i actually am making more money
now with my writing than
i am in uh in my science career some
actually became the number two book in
england uh in september
which is extremely unusual for book of
short stories
um the part that's been the most amazing
to me about it is that
both atheists and religious people
really like it so the book is blurbed by
all these famous
uh militant atheists yeah i mean people
like philip pullman and brian green now
they
they think it's and then it also got
awarded the best spiritual book of the
year by this christian website
and i thought that's great i you know
everybody's finding something that
resonates with them in there
and and what's your religious
affiliation so i call myself a
possibilian
and
and we're going to end with your answer
to this question
spell it out what's the possibility and
then you know do we join or what do we
do here
here's my yeah just a small membership
fee
um
here's been my take on it as a sign what
a life in science really teaches you
is the limits of our knowledge what you
learn is that the stuff that we don't
know vastly outstrips what we do know
right and even with all the tremendous
progress of science you're standing at
the end of the pier and it's all
uncharted waters that you know how to
build consciousness from pieces of parts
dark matter dark energy quantum
mechanics it's all
completely mysterious um so
given that i've you know there are there
are all these new books
by by the new atheists uh dennis and
dawkins and hitchens
these are fantastic books they're very
important unfortunately it's given the
the public sort of a misconception about
scientists
that a lot of the public has walked away
thinking okay scientists are acting like
all right we've got it all figured out
there's nothing else to talk about here
and that's really unfortunate because
the fact is that we do not know enough
to commit to that sort of viewpoint of
acting like we've got it all figured out
at the other end of the spectrum we know
way too much to commit to any particular
religion
so that leaves me somewhere in the
middle and so what happened about
uh 14 months ago i was on npr and and i
was asked if i was atheist i said no we
know too little and i religious no
so i said i was a possibilian and what
happened is by the time
you know so i explained that possibilism
is an active exploration
of new ideas and the idea is to shine a
flashlight around the possibility space
just to instead of pretending like you
know the answer to something you can't
possibly know
so what happened is i left the live
interview and by the time i got back to
my neuroscience lab i logged into my
email
and i had hundreds of emails from people
saying hey i think i'm a possibilian too
and so uh so i looked on google and the
word didn't exist so i did so i did what
anybody would do i bought
possibility.com
and then i and then
[Applause]
and then i've just and then i've just
been watching what's happened and it's
grown to thousands and thousands
of hits on the web and people i think
are a little tired of the debates
between dawkins and the discovery
institute
and what they want is sort of you know
instead of pretending like you know they
want a little bit of celebration of the
vastness of our ignorance and of
uncertainty and that's what
possibilities
is about her
thank you that was great
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
you